Not sure if this question went through if somebody has very dense breast and
Cancer is in the breast is a diagnostic mammogram dangerous because of
The compression would be better to wait till I get an appointment for
Molecular imaging at male clinic if I have had a thermography appointment as well. Thanks
Well from a
Medical standpoint they will you know, that's gonna be just their protocol. So if you go in to standard of care treatment for
You know, you know, say you have a suspected lump in the breast. It's gonna be mammogram
ultrasound and
biopsy I mean, you know with very little sway to any of those things. Now, we've had lots of people that said I don't want to do mammogram
You know, I don't I did there's dangers to that. It's radiation. I just want to do an ultrasound
And I'm willing to do a biopsy, but I did you know
So you can push back in the defense on your doctor and your relationship with that doctor. How much
Lee way you're gonna have with that you may have to bite somebody that will work with you. So
But there that's what's called standards of care. So in
The practice of medicine if they don't follow standards of care, they risk getting lawsuits
So they're gonna all follow standards of care and gone other days are a
Marcus well-being tried to care for the patient individually
Everybody's just trying to cover their behind and
Everybody, you know, the doctors don't rule anymore. It used to be that the one older doctor would run be running the hospital because he was really good at
Administration and the rest of the doctors, you know, made clinical decisions based upon their education
That's that's just isn't there anymore doctors are just technicians
They're following right what's on the computer screen telling them what to do and if they don't do that they get docked and
I would hate to be a medical doctor in the in the standards of care. You can't think anymore
They've just taken that completely off the table. So
Yeah, so you're gonna have to you know, make the best decision. What's best for you?
to try and find a doctor that will work with you